ok let's get started so before I get
into logic a few announcements the exam
is tomorrow remember that next week is
Thanksgiving break so we won't have any
classes there's no more sections and
after you guys come back from
Thanksgiving break on the Monday there's
going to be a poster session from 2:30
to 5:30 so there's more details on the
website and we'll post more details on
Piazza as well and then finally the day
after there is a logic homework due so
that's pretty much it aside from the
final report of things that you should
keep track of in this class I want to
take a few minutes to talk about coda
lab worksheets so this is a platform
that we've been developing our group to
help help people do research in a more
efficient and reproducible way and the
thing that's relevant for 2:21 is that
you will get a opportunity to get extra
credit by using collab worksheets and
also it provides additional compute if
you're running low on that as well I
want to give a quick demo to give you an
idea of how this works
so if you go over to worksheets that
co.org you can register for an account
I'm going to demo a kind of a newer
interface that you're actually gonna see
on the website just because that's
what's gonna be rolled out soon so let's
create a worksheet CSTO and demo a
worksheet is like a jupiter notebook if
you are familiar with that and you can
do things like write up write text so
i'm going to run some sentiment
classification
yeah let me try - I always spell this
correctly so let's suppose this the
title SC 21 final project okay and then
you can upload code or data so I'm going
to go ahead and upload the sentiment
data set hopefully this sounds familiar
to some of you and then I'm also going
to upload this text class now py which
is a source code so each of these
resources data or code is called a
bundle in code allowed and you can look
at the contents of this bundle you can
download it and so on it has a unique ID
which specifies forever
the precise version of this asset and
now the the interesting thing you can do
with this right now is you can run
commands so cool lab it's pretty
flexible you can run basically any
command you want you specify the
dependencies that this command will need
to rely on and then you can type in
whatever text class not your Y train
polarity train test polarity test and
then you hit confirm you can also see
over here you can specify how much
resources you want whether you want GPUs
where you need to access the network and
so on so this goes and creates a docker
image that's actually running or docker
container that's actually running this
command and you can visualize the
standard output in kind of real time as
the command is is running and you can
see the files that are generated so for
example one of these files is just a
JSON file that has the test error in it
so suppose you wanted to visualize the
your experiments a little bit better
because this is kind of just the default
information how much house big the
bundle is and so on you can go this is a
little bit more events but I want to
show you how this works you can define
custom schemas so if you define a schema
which is called run you add just some
fields you can actually specify test
error as a custom field
and you say go to stat saw json read it
out and and then now you use that table
to the scheme at the finest table you
can see this is the tester let me make
this a little bit nicer and format it to
three decimal places okay and then you
can go in you can modify this command
and as you say rerun maybe i wanted to
try some other parameters this ada is
the the step size let's try some more
you can rerun this 0.2 and so on so you
can fire a bunch of jobs and you can
kind of monitor them so this one's
running this one's created and you can
monitor kind of various statistics that
you want so this is generally a good way
to just launch jobs and kind of you know
forget about it and keep keep track of
all these things so then you can say
larger step sizes are hurt accuracy or
something so the idea behind a worksheet
like in jupiter is that you document
your experiments as you go along and so
every asset data code and bundles and
the experiments are all kind of treated
the same way so that you can go in here
and six months later and you know
exactly what command you ran to get this
result and the exact dependencies so
there's kind of no question so you
should think about this as kind of a get
four experiments and if you go to the
main side you can actually fire some
jobs with GPUs on them there depending
how many people are using it there might
be a queue or my not so if you have want
some extra compute that's a good way to
go as well question
how much memory can you typically get so
there's so one thing that if you want to
find out so it varies depending on what
kind of races are available but if you
type any sort of command like free you
can actually see the exact environment
that your job is running so I think on
you can get like maybe let's say 10 or
16 gigs of memory yeah
any other questions about this so
there's some documentation here and if
there's any issues that you run into a
file or github request or email me or
something Piazza won't have the highest
of you know you can post on Piazza too
but it'll be probably faster if you
submit a github issue because I'll go
directly to the team that's working on
this yeah does this work only with
Python you can run any command you want
so you can C++ Java it's it's yeah you
can run it on Julia so the thing when
you do a run you specify the docker
image which is basically contains your
environment so if you have Julia
probably has docker images available we
have a default one that has I don't I'm
not sure if it has Julia but it but it
has kind of the standard Python
tensorflow pipe torch libraries yeah
yeah so if you want to install some
dependencies there's two things you can
do you can build your own docker image
which you know takes a little bit work
but it's not too hard or you can if you
want to be lazy you can just do pip
install here in the command and you for
that you have to make sure you turn on
network access so it can actually
download from pipe I yeah yeah you can
have the requirements file yeah does
this support pop-up windows no this is
more like a batch run so the way there's
there's several ways you can do this
there's uh you can actually expose like
a port so you can connect if you're
using tensor board or something you can
actually connect to your job on the fly
or you can actually there's a way to
mount the contents of your bundle while
it's running to a local disk and you can
run whatever scripts you want maybe a
hold of further questions you come talk
to me afterwards if your if you're
interested in want to know more okay
just wanted to make that clear that that
thing is available go check it out okay
so back to the topic that we've been
discussing so on last Wednesday we
introduced of logic and remember there's
three ingredients of logic there's the
syntax which defines a set of valid
formulas for example in propositional
logic it's rain and what is a particular
formula so syntax formulas are just
symbols they have no intrinsic meaning
to themselves the way us define meaning
is by specifying the semantics so we
talked about the interpretation function
which takes a formula and a model which
represents state of the world and
returns either true or false and the way
you should think more generally about a
formula is that a
carves out a set of models which are
configurations of world where the
formula is true so in this case there
are four possible models and rain and
wet corresponds to this set of models
which are in red here where it's raining
and wet and finally we talked about
inference rules where if you have a
knowledge base which is a set of
formulas what new formulas can be you
know derived so one important thing to
remember is that these formulas are not
meant to can replace the knowledge base
these are things which are derived which
could be very simple things as you might
you have a lot of knowledge about the
world but you might want on it any given
context you might know that it's it's
raining which is so f is much generally
much smaller than the knowledge base in
terms of complexity so for rain and wet
you can derive rain okay so in general
we run inference what does it mean to do
launch going friends you have a
knowledge base and then you have a set
of inference tools that you keep on
turning and turning and then you see if
you produce W sorry F so an example we
saw last time was modus ponens which
says if you have wet and weekday and
wedding week a implies traffic then you
can derive traffic so the things on the
top are called premises and the things
on the bottom are called is the
conclusion and more generally you have
this a modus ponens inference rule so
now the question is what does this
inference will have to do with semantics
because the this is just simple
manipulation you just you saw these
symbols you produce some other symbols
and in order to anchor this in semantics
we talked about soundness and
completeness so entailment is a property
between a relationship between a
knowledge base and a formula which is
given by the models right so the models
of F have to be a super set of models of
Kb
that's the definition of entailment and
separately we have the notion of
derivation which is simple manipulation
you can derive F given a set of
inference rules from KB and soundness
means that the set of formulas that you
derive are always entailed and
completeness means that you can derive
all the entailed formulas so remember
this a water glass analogy where this
set of things in the glass are true
entailed formulas and you want to you
know stay within a glass but you don't
want to spill over so so far we've
looked at propositional logic which is
any legal combination of symbols
propositional symbols and their
connectives we also look at a subset of
that called propositional logic with
horn clauses where all the formulas look
like this you have and of a bunch of
propositional symbols implies some other
propositional symbol and so there's a
trade-off here so we saw that
propositional logic is not if you use
modus ponens improvisation logic your
you're gonna be sound but you're not
gonna come be complete there are certain
types of formulas which which you won't
be able to derive so we could either
restrict a propositional logic to only
horn clauses and we show last time that
this indeed is complete or we can say we
really want propositional logic the full
expressive power and instead we're gonna
do this King called resolution which
we're gonna talk about in this lecture
okay so this lecture has two parts we're
going to talk about resolution for
propositional logic and then move on to
first-order logic
yeah
is your attire asking about this last
statement or so is the question is
anything I can do with the last one in I
can do with a previous second-to-last
one depends on what you mean by do so
these are different statements about
expressive power and inference rules
propositional logic subsumes
propositional logic with only horn
clauses so you could just say I only
care about propositional logic but it
turns out this is going to be
exponential time and this is going to be
linear time so there's a trade-off there
yeah so what is completeness I'm using a
very precise way to talk about of a
completeness of a logical system a set
of inference rules means that anything
that is entailed by the semantics of
propositional logic is derived Bal via a
set of rules and this particular set of
rules here is modus ponens for this case
and then resolution for this case yeah
so the completeness is really a property
of resolution of the inference rule with
respect to a particular object yeah any
other questions
okay so let's dive into resolution now
so let's revisit one clauses and try to
grow them a little bit to do that we're
gonna take this example home clause a
implies C and we're gonna write it with
disjunction for reasons that will become
clear in in a second
I'm gonna write some of these identities
on you know the board so these are
things which are hopefully you you know
I also wrote this last time this is just
just true I guess this is I want to say
definition but it's not really the
definition because the definition is the
the the interpretation function but you
can check the two by two truth table and
this is no true intuitively P implies Q
really just is the same as saying either
P is false or Q is true if P is false
then the kind of the the hypothesis is
false so it's irrelevant what Q is and
if Q is true then then the whole
statement is true okay
so what about this a.m. and B implies C
so I can write it as not a or not B or C
so this invokes another identity so
which is that if I have not of P and Q
that's the same as not P or not Q okay
so and there's also another version
which is P or Q negated is the same as P
not P and not Q so what I'm doing
intuitively is pushing this negation
past the the connective into the
propositional symbols and when I push it
past
negation pass and it flips to an or and
when I push a pass an aura flips to an
end okay and hopefully you guys should
be comfortable with this because when
you're doing programming and you're
writing if statements you should know
about yeah yeah it's a good question so
the word is the order of operations it's
here it's a and B parenthesis implies C
okay so if you apply the second identity
on the board here you have a and B is
not a or not B and then you apply the
the first identity and that thing or C
is is the same thing over here okay so
now I'm going to introduce some
terminology first is a literal so this
is going to be either a propositional
symbol or it's communication there's a
notion of a clause which is just you
know disjunction of literals so the
structure means or so these things are
all clauses and finally there is a
particular type of clause called a horn
clause which I introduced last time but
here I'm defining in a kind of a
different light here which is clauses
that have at most one positive literal
okay so in these clauses there is indeed
only one positive literal so these are
horn clauses if you remember from last
time if you have snow or traffic I'll
have appearing on the right hand side
then that has two positive literals
which is which means it's not a horn
clause so now I can write modus ponens
the following way so a and a implies C
which can be written as a disjunction
allows me to derive C
and here is another intuition which is
that I'm kind of effectively canceling
out a and not a and I'm taking the you
know the resulting things I'm putting
them on the bottom okay alright so now
let's introduce the resolution rule so
general clauses could have any number of
literals so this is not a horn clause
but it is a clause and the resolution
rule for a particular this particular
example looks like this so rain or snow
and if you have not snow or traffic
allows you to derive rain or traffic
okay so this is not a horn clause right
because I have two positive literals and
how do we intuitively understand what's
going on so you could say okay it's
either rainy or snowing and snow implies
traffic which means that it was it was
snowing that I can get traffic there was
not snowing I still have rain here so I
can I can conclude it's either rainy or
trafficking so in general the resolution
rule looks like this so you have a
clause up here with some P Papa's you
know symbol and then you have the second
clause with not P and what you can do is
you can cancel out P and not P and then
you can take everything else and then
hook them up as a big you know clause
okay so this is a rule I've kind of
sketchily argue that it's a reasonable
thing to do but to really formally
verify that you have to check the
soundness and the way you do soundness
remember how do you check soundness you
go back to the semantics and of
propositional logic and you verify that
that's consistent with what resolutions
trying to do so in this rule you have
rain or snow the set of models of rain
or snow is everything that's not white
here the set of models have not snow or
traffic is everything that's not white
over here and when you intersect them
you get the dark red and that that
represents your where you think the
state of the world is if you only have
the the premises and if you look at the
models of the conclusion rain or traffic
it's this green area and you just have
to check that what you derived is a
superset of what you know and again this
might be a little bit counterintuitive
but you should think about knowledge as
restriction knowledge means that you
actually have pinpointed the state of
the world to be smaller so this fewer
colored boxes you have the more
knowledge you have okay so this is sound
completeness is another much harder
thing to check yeah question you
mentioned that we wanted to have a super
set at the end not a subset but there's
the two topmost room tiles for snow
alone or snow room yeah that are not
there is that because we've eliminated
this is so why are these there this is
so this this square is only true in rain
or snow this is only true in not snow or
traffic's but remember the the way to
think about a knowledgebase is the
semantics is an intersection of all the
four models of all the formulas so when
I've intersected the models of
everything up here I'm only left with a
dark red there's well there's two these
two I will after those because of the
fact that here it's our conclusion is
rain or traffic but I'm just sort of
wondering when you're mentioning this
two percent versus subset conclude so
let's see why are the ones up here not
included because they're not part of the
intersection so here's your question why
are these squares not part of the
intersection so they're not let me
clarify so if you only look at the
premises up here the set of models is
this Square this square this square in
this square then you look at the
premises are sorry the conclusion and
look at the models independently of the
premises and you get these six squares
yeah so this is the green is just
arrived from the the green yeah alright
so it turns out that resolution is also
complete and this is you know kind of
the big result from the sixties that
demonstrate that even a kind of a single
rule can kind of rule of propositional
logic but you might say wait a minute
wait a minute there's clearly things
that this resolution rule doesn't work
on because it only works on clauses so
what do you have what if you have
formulas that aren't clauses at all so
there's a kind of this trick that we're
going to do is that we're going to
reduce all formulas to clauses okay so
another definition that is important
here is CNF so it stands for conjunctive
normal form so a CNF formula is just a
conjunction of clauses okay so here is
an example of CNF formula here's a
clause here's a clause and you can join
them so it's important to remember that
so just to refresh so this is a CNF
formula
it's a conjunction of clauses each
clause is a disjunction of literals and
each literal is either proposition or
symbol or its negation okay so or is on
the inside and is on the outside and the
one way to kind of make sure you
remember that is a knowledge base
remember is a set of formulas but really
it represents the conjunction of all
those formulas because you know all the
facts in your knowledge base and so you
can think about of CNF formula is just
of the knowledge base were each formula
has a clause okay so we can actually
take any formula in propositional logic
and we can convert it into equivalent
CNF formula which I'll show in the next
slide
and once we've done that then we can use
resolution and life is good okay so the
conversion is going to be just a six
step procedure and the I mean it's a
little bit grungy but but I just want to
kind of highlight the general intuition
so we have this formula so this is not a
CNF formula but we're gonna make it one
okay so the first thing we want to do is
we want to remove all the symbols that
aren't ands or ORS or negation because
those definitely don't show up in this
in a clause or CNF formula so we can use
the identity the first identity on the
board to convert implication into a knot
and or you do that for the inner guy
here and now you only have symbols that
you're supposed to have the second thing
is that remember the order in which
these connectives is important for CNF
so negation is on the very inside
negation is only allowed to touch a
propositional symbol then you have or
disjunction on and then you have and so
we want to change the order so that that
is is true so first we want to push the
negation all the way inside and this is
using the de Morgan's laws so the first
the second and third identities on the
board and so we push this inside so that
now all the negation is on the on the
inside we can remove double negation you
can check very easy to check that that's
valid and finally so this is not us
CNF formula it might look like one but
it's not if you turn your head upside
down it actually looks like a CNF
formula but the reason is that and is on
the inside but it really should be on
the outside
and to fix that you can actually
distribute or over and which allows you
to say this is summer or if is a bizarre
and not snow or bizarre okay so now this
is a CNF formula and then you're done
this is a general set of rules just to
recap you eliminate bi-directional
implication implication to get the
symbol inventory right and then you move
negation all the way to the inside and
you need limonade in a spurious negation
that you don't need and then you move
any or from the outside to inside the
the and okay so long story store take
any propositional logical formula you
can make it a CNF formula so without
loss of generality we're just going to
assume we have CNF formulas okay
another place that CNF form you might
have seen CNF formulas come up is when
you're talking about in theoretical
computer science when you're talking
about 3sat 3sat is a problem where
you're given a CNF formula where every
clause has three symbols and three
literals and you're trying to determine
if it's satisfiable here we know that to
be a very hard problem okay so so now
let's talk about the resolution
algorithm remember there is a
relationship between entailment and
contradiction so knowledge base entails
F is the same as saying knowledge base
is incompatible with not F like F really
really must hold it's it's impossible
that not F you know holds okay so
suppose we wanted to prove that F is
derived from the knowledge base what
we're going to do is this proof by
contradiction strategy where we're going
to say insert non F into the knowledge
base
see if we can derive a contradiction
okay so you add naught F into a
knowledge base convert all the formulas
into CNF and then you keep on reapplying
the resolution rules and you return
entailment if you can derive false ok so
here's an example over this looks like
so here's a knowledge base and here's a
particular formula and I want to know
whether KB entails F or not okay so you
add it add not F into knowledge base so
that's not C and I'm gonna convert this
into a CNF so that only affects the
first formula here and then I'm gonna
repeatedly apply the resolution rule so
I can take this clause resolution says
allows me to cancel not a with a I get B
or C and then I take B and not B cancel
it out C and I cancel out C I mean when
you see see and not see that's clearly a
contradiction and you can derive false
which means that the knowledge base
entails f in this particular example
okay this also maybe gives a little bit
intuition of the mysteries of defining
the goal clause and horn clauses as
deriving of blah blah blah and implies
false because you can add something that
you're trying to prove and you can use
modus ponens to see if you can derive
false and if you do derive false then
it's a it's a contradiction alright so
as I alluded to before there's a time
complexity difference between modus
ponens and a resolution so for modus
ponens each rule application adds only
adds a clause with one propositional
symbol so imagine you have n
propositional symbols you can really
only apply modus ponens and times so
that's linear number of applications
there whereas the thing with resolution
is that you can add each rule
application can add a clause with many
propositional symbols and in the worst
case you can imagine any subset of the
propositional symbols can be added and
this results in the exponential time
algorithm this should not be surprising
because we know that 3sat is you know MP
complete so unless there were some magic
here there's there's no way there kind
of circumvent that yeah
and so question is why is resolution
preferred so you could just convert
everything to CNF and check do
backtracking search or whatever on say
enough resolution turns out that ou have
generalizations to first-order logic
which model checking doesn't right so so
remember there's two ways you can go
about you can do basically reduce things
to CS piece and then you can solve it or
you can try to use inference rules so
this inference rule doesn't as far as I
know people don't really use resolution
in propositional logic but in first
order logic you kind of have no choice
the question is whether the two our
resolution looks like kind of like nan
there's quite a bit difference there
maybe you could talk about it offline
okay so summarize there's two routes
here you can say I'm gonna use
propositional logic with horn clauses
and B using modus ponens this is fast
but it's less expressive or I can
embrace the full complexity of a
propositional logic and use resolution
and this is exponential time it's slow
but it's more expressive yeah
right what do I mean by expressive I
mean the the ladder which is that
there's simply some things you can't
write down in in with using for closets
like you can't write down rain or snow
at all any sort of branching or
disjunction you can't do in one clauses
so in some applications horn clauses
actually turns out to be you know quite
and enough so these type of horn clauses
show up and programming languages where
you're just you know you see some
premises and you're trying to derive
some other quantities so like in program
analysis this is actually quite useful
and efficient okay so let's move to for
serologic so what's wrong with
propositional logic I mean it's already
exponential time so you know it better
be pretty good so remember the point of
logic is to in general from AI
perspective is to be able to represent
and reason with knowledge in the world
so there's a lot of things that we want
to represent but might be awkward in
propositional logic so here's an example
so Alice and Bob both know wherever it
may take so how would you do this in
propositional logic
well propositional logic is about
propositions so this has two
propositions which are statements which
are either true or false Alice knows
arithmetic and Bob knows arithmetic okay
fine so what about all students know
arithmetic how would you represent that
well you probably do something like this
where you say okay if Alice's student an
analyst knows rhythmic if Bob is the
student involved knows arithmetic and so
on because all propositional logic can
do is reason about statements so what
about this
this is Goldbach's conjecture every even
integer greater than 2 is the sum of two
primes so good luck with that
you might we'll have to write down all
the integers which there
so propositional logic is clunky at best
and not expressive and the worse what's
missing when we have knowledge in the in
the world it's often more natural to
think about there as being objects and
predicates on these objects rather than
just opaque propositions so Alice knows
arithmetic actually has more internal
structure it's not just the single
proposition that has nothing to do with
anything else
it has notions of Alice and knows an
arithmetic in up and finally once you
can decompose a proposition into parts
you can do fancy things with them you
can use quantifiers and variables for
example all is a quantifier that applies
to each person and we want to do that
inference without you numerating over
all the people or all the integers okay
so I'm going to talk about first order
logic going through our plan if first
talking about the syntax then the
semantics and then inference rules so I
want to warm up with just some examples
I'm not gonna do as rigorous of a
treatment of first-order logic as
propositional logic because it gets more
complicated and I just want to give you
an idea of how it works
so I was involved in both no or this
picnic this is going to be represented
as there was Alice Riddick and knows Bob
arithmetic okay so this is a there are
some familiar symbols like and and now
the propositional symbols have been
replaced with these more structured
objects and all students were no
arithmetic gets mapped to this where now
I have this quantifier for all X student
of X implies those X arithmetic okay so
a bit more formally so there's a bunch
of definitions I'm gonna talk about so
first-order logic
so I mean first-order logic there's two
types of things
there's terms and then there's formulas
in propositional logic there were only
formulas so terms are expressions that
refer to objects so it could be a
constant symbol it could be a variable
or it could be a function applied to
some other terms so for example
arithmetic is a is just a constant it's
a think about it as a name there are
variables like X which I'll explain
later
and there's functions of terms so 3 plus
X would be represented as sum of three
of X okay remember these are just
symbols and formulas refer to truth
values so there's atomic formulas or
atoms so this atomic formula is a
predicate apply two terms so those X is
a term a rhythmic is a term therefore a
nose is a predicate so knows X
arithmetic is an atomic formula so atoms
are supposed to be indivisible but here
there's a sub structure here so maybe
you can think about these as subatomic
particles if that is useful there's a
connectives as before so what we're
doing right now is you're taking these
atomic formulas atoms and they behave
like propositional symbols so given
these atoms are generalizations of
proposition symbols we can strain them
together using any number of connectives
as we've done in propositional logic and
then finally we have quantifiers applied
to formulas which means that if you have
a formula with a variable in it we can
stick a quantifier over these variables
to specify how the variable is meant to
be interpreted okay so no connectives
and quantifiers alright so so let's talk
about quantifiers quantifiers are in
some sense the the heart of why
first-order logic is useful there's two
types of quantifiers and Universal
quantifiers and existential quantifiers
so Universal quantifiers you change to
think about as just glorified
conjunction so what I have for all X P
of X that's really like saying P of a
and P of B and P FC and for all the
constant symbols and existential
quantifiers are glorified disjunction
when I say there exists X such that P of
X holds that's like saying P of a or P
of B or and so on its own so I'm
cheating a little bit because I'm only
I'm still talking about the syntax of
first-order logic but I can't resist but
give you a little bit of intuition about
what this syntax means I'm not formally
defining the interpretation function
here but I'm just trying to give you an
idea of what the symbols correspond to
so here are some properties so if I push
a negation through a universal
quantification then that goes on and
inside and the for all becomes and
exists does this sound familiar to
people or what is the name for this kind
of thing yeah it's just the Morgan's law
about apply to first-order logic and
supposed to process show logic and it's
really important to remember that the
order of quantifiers matters right so
for all exist is very different from
exists for all okay so one more comment
about quantifiers it will be useful to
be able to convert natural language
sentences into you know first-order
logic and on the assignment you're gonna
do a bunch of this but so this is kind
of
there's an important distinction I want
to make so a natural language you talk
have quantifiers in natural language are
words like every or some or and so how
do these get represented in in formal
logic every student knows arithmetic
every generally refers to for all so you
might write something like this but this
is wrong so what's wrong about this
sorry saying it yeah so so the problem
is that what does this say this is says
everyone's a student for all X X's is
soon and for all X X notes rivers so
it's basically saying everyone's a
student and everyone knows a resident
egg which is different so what it really
should be is implication right so for
anyone that's not a student I don't I
don't care in terms of this assessing
the validity of this formula and only if
someone's a student then I'm gonna check
whether that student knows arithmetic
okay so what about existential
quantification some new student knows
arithmetic this is student of X and
knows X rithmetic so those are different
connectives and a general rule of thumb
is that whenever you have Universal
quantification it should be implication
and whenever you have existential
quantification it should be an and so of
course there is exceptions but this is
the general rule okay so let me give you
a few examples just just to get you used
to think about quantifiers so imagine
you want to say there is some course
that every student has taken so what how
is that so there exist some course so
there should be a exist why why is a
course that every student has taken so
every is it for all X and here I want
student implies takes XY okay remember
exist has usually has and and for all
has implies okay what about go box
conjecture every integer is greater than
grand two is sum of two primes this is
every even integer so every even integer
greater than two implies that what about
these is the sum of two primes so notice
that there are no may be explicit hints
that you need to use X essential but the
fact that these two primes are kind of
under specify means that it should be
exist so there exists Y & Z such that
both of my prime and the sum of x y&z is
X and finally here's the statement if a
student takes a course in the course
covers a concept then the student knows
that concept whether that's true or not
is a different matter but this is a
valid formula and it's can be written as
follows so one other you know piece of
advice is that if you see word if that
generally suggests that there's a bunch
of Universal quantifications because if
it's kind of like saying there's a
general rule and Universal
quantification says like in general you
know something happens so this is for
all X or Y all Z if you have a student
and takes some course and that course
covers some concept Z then that student
knows that concept I guess technically
there should be also and concept of Z in
there but spread it getting complicated
ok any questions about first order logic
what the syntax is and any of these
intuitions and that we're having for it
so the question is why don't we just use
the equal sign so I'm being a little bit
uh I guess cautious and you know
following the strict syntax where you
have functions that just take longer it
gives you it shows you the structure of
the logical expressions more so now in
certain cases you you can use syntactic
sugar and you can write equals if you
want but remember the point of logic is
not to be able to write these things
down manually and a reason with them but
to have a very kind of primitive really
built system formulas that you have
general rules like resolution that can
operate on them ok so let's talk about
the semantics of first-order logic
so in propositional logic a model was
something that map's propositional
symbols to truth values in other words
it's a complete assignment of truth
values to propositional symbols so what
is this infrastruc so still we're gonna
maintain the intuition that a model is
supposed to represent a possible
situation in the world so we're gonna
give you of kind of some grant a
graphical intuition so imagine you only
have unary and binary predicate s-- so
these are predicates that only take one
or two arguments then we can think about
a model as being represented as a graph
so imagine you have three notes these
represents two objects in the world
so objects are kind of first-class
citizens in for sort of logic and these
are labeled with constant symbols so you
have Alice you have Bob and Robert and
you have arithmetic here and then the
directed edges
is our gonna represent binary predicate
and and these are going to be labeled
with the predicate symbols so here I
have a nose predicate that applies to O
103 another nose predicate that applies
to o two or three and a unary predicate
here that applies to only a one okay so
more formally a model in first order
logic is a mapping that takes any every
constant symbol to an object so Alex
goes 0 1 Bob goes over to over the MCOs
0 3 and it maps predicate symbols to
tuples of objects so nose is a set of
pairs such that the first element of
pair knows the second element of the
pair
I'm skipping function symbols just from
simplicity but you would define them
analogously as well okay so that is a
model it's a little bit more complicated
than propositional logic because you
have to define something for both the
turn of the constant symbols and the
predicate symbols so now to make our
lives a little bit easier I'm gonna
introduce a restriction on model and
it's motivator the following example so
if I say John and Bob are students then
in your head you might imagine well
there's two people John and Bob and
they're both students but there could be
technically only one person whose name
is both John and Bob or someone who's
anonymous and doesn't have a name and
there's two simplifications that rule
out w2 and w3 so your unique names
consumption says that object has most
each object has at most one constant
symbol and domain closure says that each
symbol has at least one constant symbol
so the point of this restriction means
that constant symbols and objects are in
one-to-one relationship
and once you do that then we can do
something called propositional ization
and in this case a first-order logic is
actually just a syntactic sugar for a
propositional logic so if you have this
knowledge base and first-order logic
student of Alice and BA soon enough Bob
for all all students are people and
there's some creative student then you
can actually convert very simply into
propositional logic by kind of unrolling
it's like unrolling your loops in some
sense so we just have student and Alice
implies person Alice student Bob implies
person Bob and because there's a finite
set of prop constant symbols it's not
gonna be a infinite set of formulas
there might be a lot of formulas but
it's not going to be here for that set
okay so the point of doing this is now
you can use any inference algorithm for
propositional logic for first-order
logic okay so if you're willing to make
this restriction unique names and domain
closure that means you kind of have
direct access to all the objects in in
the world via via your constant symbols
in which case you've you're just
propositional you just have
propositional logic okay so why might
you want to do this so first our logic
as as a syntactic sugar still might be
convenient you might still want to write
down your expressions in first order
logic and have the benefits of actually
having you know propositional logic
where the inference is in some sense
much more you know developed but later
we'll see that there's some cases where
you won't be able to you know do this
okay so that's all I'm gonna say about
the semantics of first-order logic so
now let's talk about inference rules
okay so I'm gonna start by talking about
first-order logic with horn clauses and
we're gonna use some generalization of
modus ponens and then we're gonna move
to full-on first-order logic and talk
about the generalization of resolution
okay so let's begin by defining definite
clauses for first-order logic so
remember a definite clause in
propositional logic was a conjunction of
propositional symbols implies some other
propositional symbol and now the
propositional symbols are now these
atoms atomic formulas and furthermore we
have might have variables so we're going
to have quite universal quantifiers on
outside so intuitively you should think
about this as a single template that
gets real if you were to propositional
eyes it would be a whole set of definite
formulas in a propositional logic so
this another way to think about this is
that this single statement is a very
compact way of writing down what would
be very kind of cumbersome in
propositional logic because you would
have to instantiate all the possible
symbols okay so here's a formal
definition so a definite Clause has a
following form
you start by a set having a set of
variables which are all universally
quantified and then you have atomic
formulas which are all conjoined implies
another atomic formula and these atomic
formulas can contain any of these
variables okay
so now let's do modus ponens so here's a
straightforward generalization of modus
ponens you have some atomic formulas a 1
through a K that you pick up and then
you have a 1 through a K implies B and
then you use that to derive B ok so it
says the first attempt so you might
assume I catch on the fact that this
actually won't work so why doesn't it
work
so imagine you have pee valise and then
you have for all X P of X implies Q of X
so the problem is that you can't
actually infer a Q of Alice at all
because P of X here and P of Alice just
don't match right this is supposed to be
a 1 this is supposed to be a 1 and P of
X and P of Alice are not the same a 1 so
this is kind of an important lesson
because you remember these inference
rules don't know anything they have no
kind of intrinsic semantics there's just
pattern matching right so if you don't
write your patterns right then it's just
not going to work but we can fix this
and the solution involves two ideas
substitution and unification so
substitution is taking a formula
applying a final replace to generate
another formula so if I want to replace
X with LS apply to P of X I get P of
Alice I can do to find replaces X with
Alice and Y with Z and I gonna replace X
with Alice and why would see and so in
general a substitution theta is some
mapping from variables to terms and
substitution theta of f returns the
result of just performing that
substitution on F so it generates
another formula with these variables
replaced with these terms so pretty
simple idea ok unification takes two
formulas and tries to make them the same
and to make that I'm saying you have to
do some substitution so it returns one
substitution and need it to do that ok
so here's an example knows Alice
arithmetic knows X arithmetic these
expressions are not syntactically
identical but if I replace X with Alice
then they are identical so that's when
your vacation does so what about this
how do I make these two identical I
replace X with Alice and why was e and
what about this one I can't do anything
because I can't I can only remember
substitution only can replace variables
with other things it can't replace
constant symbols so it can't replace a
light sweet ball so that just fails and
then things can get a little bit more
complicated when you have functional
symbols so here to make these the same I
need to replace X with Alice and then Y
with F of X but X has already been
replaced with Alice so I need to make
this Y goes to F of Alice okay so to
summary summarize a unification takes
two formulas F and G and returns a
substitution which maps variables to
terms and this is the most general
unifier which means that if I a unify X
and X I could also replace X with Alice
and that we find but that's not the most
general thing I want to substitute as
little as possible to make two things
equal so unify returns the substitutions
such that and here's an important
property if I apply that substitution to
F I get identically the same expression
as if I apply the data to G and if I
can't do it then I just fail okay so now
yeah question so the question is F f of
X is this a variable or a formula so f
of X F is a function symbol so it takes
a term and returns a term so the
technical term f of X is a term which
represents an object in the world and
you can check that knows is a is a
predicate so it needs to take terms so f
of X visitor
okay so now with substitution
unification we can now revise our modus
ponens to make it work so I'm going to
have a 1 prime through a K prime which
are distinct syntactically from 8th a 1
through a K and what I'm gonna do is try
to unify the primes and the not Prime's
into some substitution and once I have
the substitution I can apply this to be
and derive B Prime and that's what I'm
gonna write down okay so let me do go
through this example now so suppose
Alice has taken 221 and 221 covers MVP's
and I have this general rule that says
if a student takes a course and the
course covers topics then that Suman
knows that topic so I'm need to unify
this takes Alice 221 covers 221 MVP with
this abstract version and when I unify I
get the substitution to be X you need to
repeat a replace with Alice Y with 221
and Z with MDP and then I can derive
I'll and then I take this theta and I
apply that substitution to knows X Z and
I get knows Alice MDP so intuitively you
can think about a 1 prime into 8 K prime
these are concrete this is concrete
knowledge you have about the world this
is a general rule so what the
substitution does is it specifies how
the general variables here are to be
grounded in the concrete things that
you're dealing with and now this final
substitution grounds it out grounds this
part into the concrete symbols in this
case Alice 221 and MDP
okay so what's the complexity of this so
each application of modus ponens
produces an atomic formula just one not
multiple one so that that's the good
news
and if you don't have any functions
symbols the number of atomic formulas is
most the number of constant symbols to
the maximum predicate already so in this
case if you have like a hundred possible
values of X hundred possible values of Y
a hundred possible values of Z that
would be the number of possible formulas
that you might produce is a hundred to
the third so you know that could be met
you can imagine this being a very very
large number so it's exponential in the
arity but if the arity is you know let's
say two then you know this is not too
bad it's not exponential so that's
that's a good news the bad news from a
complexity point of view is if there are
function symbols then actually that's
infinite like it's not just an
exponential time it's like infinite
infinite time because the number of
possible formulas that you could produce
is kind of unbounded and when what might
you have something like this well if you
remember one of the functions could be
some so you could have like some one and
some of one and some of one and so on so
you can kind of essentially encode
arithmetic using this first-order logic
okay so so here's what we know
so modus ponens is complete for force or
logic with only horn clauses all right
so what does completeness mean it means
that anything that's actually true
that's entailed there exists a
derivation a way of applying modus
to get there but the bad news is that
it's semi decidable this means so first
order logic even when you restrict it to
horn clauses this semi decidable this
means what if F is in entailed forward
inference using complete inference rules
in this case our modus ponens will
eventually prove or derive F in finite
time because it's complete so eventually
you would get it but if if it's not
entailed we don't know we don't know
when to stop because it could go just
keep on going on and on and actually no
algorithm can show this in finite time
so this is a complexity throughout a
result that says it's not just
exponential time but it's actually
there's no algorithm it's like if you're
familiar with a halting problem that's
this is very related to that okay so
that's a bummer but you know it's it's
not the end of the world because you can
still actually just run inference and
get a partial result so you might
succeed in which you know for sure
because it's sound that it's the F is
entailed and after a while well you just
run out of CPU time and you stop and
then you say I don't know ok so now
let's talk about resolution so we've
finished talking about first-order logic
with restricted to horn clauses and we
saw that modus ponens is complete
there's a small wrinkle that you can't
actually compute everything that you
hope for but that's life and now we're
going to go to resolution so remember
that first order logic includes no more
clauses so here's an example so this has
all
students know something and the fact
that this is it exists here
remember existential quantification is
like glorified disjunction so this is
like our example of no snow or traffic
so what do we do with this so we're
gonna follow the same strategy as what
we did for propositional logic we're
going to convert everything into CNF and
then we're gonna repeatedly apply the
resolution rule and the main thing
that's going to be different is now we
have to handle variables and quantifiers
and use substitution and unification but
the structure is going to be the same so
the conversion to CNF is a bit messy and
gross and slightly non-intuitive I just
want to present it so you know what it
looks like so here is a example of nada
seeing that formula so what does this
say just you know to practice this says
for all X so if anyone who loves all
animals is loved by someone okay and
what we want to produce is the final
output is this CNF formula which again
CNF means a conjunction of disjuncts
and each disjunct is atomic formula or
atomic formula that's been negated and
here we see some functions that have
emerged called skull on functions which
I'll explain later and that's that's
basically it so we have to handle
variables and we're gonna have to handle
somehow and the way we do this is we
remember there's no quantifiers that
show up here and by default everything
is going to be universally quantified
which means that the existential
quantifiers have to go away and the
existential quantifiers get converted
- these are functions okay all right so
part one so there's a again the sick or
I can't remember six to eight step
procedure we start with this input what
is the first thing we want to do we want
to remove all the symbols that don't
shouldn't show up get our symbol
inventory correct so we eliminate
implication this is the same as you know
before so here is this thing implies
this thing and we replace that with not
that the first thing or not the second
thing so now the expressions are more
gross but it's really the same rule that
we identity that we were invoking before
it would do that for the inner
expression we push the negation inwards
so what it touches the atomic formulas
and eliminate double negation so this is
all in old news and something new hero
is we're gonna standardize the variables
so this step is technically not
necessary by standardizing variables I
just mean that you know this Y and this
Y are actually different it's like
having two local variables into you know
different functions they have nothing to
do with each other because we're gonna
remove quantification later I'm just
gonna make them separate so this Y gets
replaced with a Z okay so now I have
this I'm going to replace existentially
quantified variables with skolem
functions okay so this requires a little
bit of explanation so I have exists Z
loves Z of X okay and this existential
is on the inside here so of this
universal quantifier fire so in a way Z
depends on X for every X I'm gonna have
a different Z so to capture this
dependency I can't just drop
um exists Z what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to capture the dependency by
turning Z into a function and the same
thing happens over here I have exists Y
and I replace this lowercase Y with a
big why that depends on the the
variables that are universally
quantified outside this the scope here
yeah so loves all animals is on in the I
guess the first part so everyone who
likes all animals is loved by someone so
this is the sum one part because here I
push the negation inside yeah yeah so
remember when I push negation if pasta
for all it becomes it exists okay so now
I can distribute or over and to change
the order of the of these connectives so
that because in CNF I want a conjunction
of disjuncts not a disjunction of
conjuncts and finally I just ditch all
the universal quantifiers okay okay so I
don't expect you to you know follow all
that in a complete detail but this is
just giving you a basic idea okay so now
we're ready to state the resolution rule
and this should look very familiar it's
the same resolution rule as before but
now all of these things are not
propositional symbols but atomic formula
and now this is not P and not P but P
and not Q and I because these in general
might be different and I need to unify
them and then I would take the
substitution return by unification and
I'm gonna apply it on the result it's
the same way we did for
modus ponens so here's an example of
this I have animal Orlov's
and over here I have not loved or feeds
and what do I do I try to unify this
love's with this not loves and I get
this substitution so you has to replace
with Z of X and V with X and that allows
me to cancel these now now I've made
them equal and now I take the remaining
parts and I apply the substitution so
this feeds you of V becomes feeds Z of X
and X okay so there's a bit more
intuition I can provide but this does
become a little bit abstract and you
just kind of have to trust that
resolution is doing its job I personally
find it kind of difficult to look at
intermediate stages of logical inference
and really get any intuition about the
individual pieces but but that's why you
define the principle as prove that
they're right and then you trust that
logical inference does the right thing
okay to summarize we've talked about
propositional logic and first-order
logic
so for inference in propositional logic
you could just do model checking which
means that converted to a CSP and solve
it I mean first of all logic
there's no way to enumerate all of the
possible infinite models so you can't do
that but in certain cases you can
propositional eyes and you can reduce
versa logic to propositional logic in
certain cases or you can stick with
inference rules and if you stick with
inference tools you can use modus ponens
on the horn clauses or you can if you
don't want to restrict your horn clauses
you can use resolution and the only
thing that's different about first-order
logic here is a plus plus which means
that you have to use unification and
substitution okay um
final takeaway is you know there's a lot
of kind of similar notation and details
here but I wanted to kind of
stress the importance of logic as
expressive language to represent
knowledge and reason with that and the
key idea in first or logic is the use of
variable so these are very not the same
notion of variables as in in CSPs those
variables are propositional symbols
which are like the simplest thing in
logic so in logic first-order logic
we've kind of gone up of kind of a layer
in the expressive hierarchy and
variables here allow you to you know or
give compact representations to a very
rich thing so again that kind of you
don't remember anything just to remember
the takeaway that logic allows you to
express very complicated and big things
using kind of small formulas okay so
that's it on the on Wednesday be giving
a lecture on deep learning and there's
one and then we have the poster session
after Thanksgiving and then the final
lecture will give that will sum
everything up so okay
I will see you at the poster session and
good luck on the exam